what is your reaction when you when you
read something like this
yes ukrainian i mean i i appreciate
their honesty right ukrainian refugees
are welcome muslim refugees are not
instagram accounts you know they're just
like us me i'm sorry it's really
emotional for me because i see
european people with blue eyes and
blonde hair you can see people can see
that right now yeah well just to put it
bluntly these are not refugees from
syria these are refugees from
uh neighboring ukraine and hypocrisy
they actually used footage of
palestinians like a palestinian girl
resisting israeli occupation when i was
in medina yeah the report came out that
medina is actually the safest city in
the world
how you guys doing it's good to have you
guys with us we got an exciting episode
we got some
we got an exciting guest here
on the d show we're going to be talking
about ukraine we're going to be talking
about africa we're going to be talking
about
all the other refugees
around the world
countries that they're coming from
that's not getting much attention
and some of the
double standards just to put it bluntly
these are not refugees from syria the
blatant hypocrisy
all that with my next guest
hassan shibli now who's that for you
those of you that don't know how shibley
is the director of philanthropy
at blacklist capital inc previous chief
executive director of care florida
the largest civil rights organization in
the state he holds a law degree from the
university of buffalo school of law an
educator and a speaker of muslim civil
rights
hassan actively works with various
interfaith and social service
organizations promoting cultural and
spiritual diversity
hassan shibli also acts as an advisor on
civil rights for various institutions
and governmental agencies and he he is
here with us on a deep show
how are you
that's my father has the same name
hassan means what does it mean again uh
handsome
dangerous
so uh you actually just got back from
africa
yes actually i'm still jet-lagged man i
got home at midnight last night
now were you in in africa when you heard
the news or was going on in ukraine yeah
i'm trying to remember if i was in
africa or saudia but yeah literally the
world fell apart i mean i just remember
and i just felt that when i got back
obviously human beings are selfish so
you think about the most direct impact
i'm filling up the gas and it it hit a
hundred dollars for the first time i'm
filling up my tank and that's when you
know uh things are going crazy but yeah
i remember when we were overseas and
just hearing about the the invasion and
just really the the
uh my ears were shocked i think at the
utter hypocrisy
of the dialogue both surrounding the
invasion and surrounding the refugee
crisis that was subsequent
you got a lot of experience with this
because you've seen a lot of
what's happened the consequences of war
and then the influx of refugees and then
the attack on refugees right and then
now it's happening you know it's sad
anytime it happens right in any country
all human life is precious but
particularly you see now in ukraine
that is being held up and you see all
the media and then you just see kind of
like what's a lot of these have you seen
some of these reporters and you know
kind of uh making the people who are
coming from afghanistan and other places
that are not european as like
uncivilized this isn't a place with all
due respect you know like iraq or
afghanistan that has seen
conflict raging for decades you know
this is a relatively civilized uh
relatively european i have to choose
those words carefully i mean the
hypocrisy is mind-boggling so i remember
being a teenager in the u.s and arguing
against the impeding invasion of iraq
and afghanistan and literally arguing at
the time i was just in school right so
you're arguing with classmates but but
why but those are the people if we don't
go get them they're going to destroy our
way of life right that's what we're
taught right and that's what would
justify
the the utter terrorism that we've
unleashed on that world they hate us
they hate us because we're blowing them
up right it's a self-created uh problem
and it's it's it's all about oil it's
about wealth it's about power it's about
hegemony and uh you know the us
unfortunately doesn't have a leg to
stand on when it comes to condemning
illegal foreign invasion i think what
blew my mind was watching condoleezza
rice speak out against the invasion and
look we're all against the the the
you know illegal invasion you know and
honestly i'll have a lot of respect for
a ukrainian citizen who takes up an
ak-47 and fires shots
at an invading russian soldier just as i
would respect the palestinian who does
the same thing against an israeli
soldier who attacks him and for that i
might be labeled an extremist but for
another i'm labeled as as modern and
articulate and the hypocrisy is they
actually used footage of palestinians
like a palestinian girl resisting
israeli occupation palestinian children
being blown up by the israeli military
they put that as ukrainians resisting
russia they actually used that footage
of palestinians resisting israel and
they mislabeled it as footage of
ukrainians resisting russia and they
supported that the same footage they
would have labeled as terrorist and
violence and evil previously now is
being celebrated why because those that
are defending their homeland look more
like the general population right as as
the reporters themselves have said
listen these are blue-eyed blonde
europeans they have netflix accounts
they have instagram accounts you know
they're just like us i'm sorry it's
really emotional for me because i see
european people with blue eyes and
blonde hair being healed children be
killed every day with putin's missiles
and his helicopters and his rockets so
we have to stand with them
meanwhile it was those same journalists
those same reporters those same elected
officials that were beating the drums of
war against the victims of iraq and
afghanistan that we killed because
frankly what they do is they just don't
value brown life as much that's what it
comes down to
they label muslims and arabs as the
other as the foreigner they otherize
them they dehumanize them they feed us
lies just like putin is feeding his
country lies to justify the illegal
invasion in the massacre and we've
literally killed millions directly or
indirectly in the middle east over the
last 30 years
you know we've done
of the greatest global acts of terrorism
and had russia done
what we're doing we condemn them in fact
we are right now we're condemning them
in in ukraine for doing what we've done
in iraq for doing what we've done in
afghanistan so we condemn what's
happening but we also condemn the united
states when it's done the very same
criminal acts of aggression let's let's
not mince words here
the invasion of iraq was criminal was
illegal it led to the deaths of hundreds
of thousands of civilians directly not
to mention indirectly
the invasion of afghanistan
was likewise illegal
the
occupation of the palestinian land and
the israeli crimes against humanity
funded by u.s tax dollars it is illegal
and just as we celebrate the ukrainians
who resist illegal occupation
why don't we celebrate the palestinians
even the iraqis even the afghanis
who have resisted
illegal invasion especially the afghanis
from empire after empire people are
afraid to say this but i say now is the
time we come out and condemn all
foreign military invasion and occupation
whether it is by russia or whether it's
by the u.s we have to be loyal to
principles and truth
not to politics and flags
when you see
people in
uk and even in the united states
and now they're coming because they're
seeing what's going on a tragedy over
there with innocent civilians and now
people are volunteering to step up
to go
and assist right have you have you seen
some of this outside ukraine's embassy
in london a steady stream of men come to
find out how they can join up to fight
you can send
email a letter for this address yeah and
he contacted with you seen that i've
seen that i've seen you know how ukraine
right now is welcoming saying any any
man who wants to come and join us in the
fight we'll give you an ak-47 join our
fight you know what look isn't that
illegal i mean according to i think
according to uk law i thought it'd be
important to caution people against that
because
of the provision of uk criminal law uh
prohibiting that
what about you i'm not an expert in in
that area of law for them um however it
looks like right now they have the
popular support i doubt anybody's going
to get arrested for supporting ukrainian
resistance you know in fact it will be
celebrated but again i say why the
hypocrisy that's the point why the why
the double standards the hypocrisy right
and i think it comes down to again other
rising right it comes down to you to you
know if the victims of invasion are
brown and that's what they said these
are white europeans they're not used to
the bloodshed you know but but as if we
we've normalized the violence that we've
created in the middle east
you know so again when it suits our
interests we we justify when we support
when the victims happen to be like us
you know white european then we uh you
know condemn it and it's hypocritical
and it's dangerous
and i hope this serves as a wake-up call
that just as the people are supporting
ukrainian right to resist they support
the palestinian right to resist
um and they support the the right of all
oppressed people to stand up against
aggression and injustice what is your
action when you when you read something
like this
yes ukrainian i mean i i appreciate
their honesty right ukrainian refugees
are welcome muslim refugees are not and
that's exactly what we're hearing we're
and that's exactly what we are seeing
you know before this problem we saw that
europe uh was dealing with a huge influx
of refugees from the middle east again
from conflicts that we created let's be
very clear
daesh
which has created other chaos in the
middle east would not have existed had
it not been for the illegal invasion of
iraq
you know we are directly responsible for
the atrocity when i say we as the
american people for the atrocities
daesh is unleashed in the middle east
and the subsequent refugee problems that
happen either as a result of daesh or
happen as a result of the corrupt
dictatorships that we support over there
that we fund over there so the reality
is we ourselves as the united states of
america with the support of europe have
created the refugee crisis in the middle
east
and what we saw when refugees were
literally escaping for their lives
to europe was closed borders was turning
away of ships was thousands and
thousands of refugees drowning to their
death while european nations stood by
so they said we cannot take in refugees
but again now that the refugees are
you know green-eyed uh blue-eyed
blond-haired you know white people
i mean i'm sorry it's really emotional
for me because i see european people
with blue eyes and blonde hair being
healed they're welcoming them with open
arms again it shows the hypocrisy even
how they speak about them right so when
they talk about european refugees they
talk about families that are victims
when they talk about muslim refugees
they try to label them just as men that
are potential aggressors you know the
rhetoric the language that is used is
very problematic and i think it just
reflects xenophobia that's all it
reflects so this is not getting into the
politics between russia
nor ukraine right
so you're talking about this is just the
blatant uh double standards in hypocrisy
right that i mean what what should
someone who is kind of obvious it's
something that now doesn't take much of
pointing out when you see obviously
again the reporters
like the many reporters who are coming
out you can see people can see that
right now yeah well just to put it
bluntly these are not refugees from
syria these are refugees from
uh neighboring ukraine i mean that
quite frankly is part of it these are um
christians they're white they're
um
they're very similar to people many
people who live in poland and this is
not a developing third world nation this
is europe this isn't a place with all
due respect you know like iraq or
afghanistan that has seen
conflict raging for decades you know
this is a relatively civilized uh
relatively european i have to choose
those words carefully okay how do you
differentiate now
civilized and uncivilized
it's it's based on skin color that's
that's how they're differentiating so is
it is this uh hidden uh racism coming
out from under from deep with inside
it's it's really i think the racism
that's within the hearts is coming out
and it's clear even and people say i
mean literally they said listen i gotta
be careful with my words but again these
are you know white european civilized
you know guys with netflix that are that
are you know the refugees now it hits
close to home and they're acknowledging
uh their prejudice without seeing a
problem with it almost you know so it's
almost like the norm you know and and
the truth
that is hidden within their hearts is
coming up look i think we need to be
people of principle
um again i'm not gonna pretend to be an
expert on what's happening in russia
ukraine you don't have to be right i
think as a on a superficial level we can
always condemn illegal invasion i think
on a superficial level we can always
respect those who take arms to defend
their land
but we have to apply that across the
board regardless of race religion or
color
you know so
as we are supportive of the people of
ukraine
in their uh fight to to protect their
land
we likewise must support the people of
palestine who do the same thing
right we must support those that are
muslim that have fought against illegal
invasion of their land for decades
you know so we apply that level and then
as we welcome
refugees
right from ukraine
likewise we should welcome
refugees from the other political
conflicts that we ourselves have created
if you look at from your experience if
you were to because you probably have
seen so much
and you just go besides the the race
issue if you just look at
this this aspect of it you know from
some of the horrific crimes that were
done from people com invading
forces going into those countries and
you've probably read the report you've
probably seen what was happening on the
ground like like what was it guantanamo
the other where they put their hands
right
yes and you've seen some of the
disgusting things so is that civilized
look here's the reality first of all
when i was in medina yeah the report
came out that medina is actually the
safest city in the world medina for
women yes medina the city of the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him is ranked
globally as the safest city in the world
for women
you know i think look the muslim
majority countries that in communities
where they actually abide by the islamic
principles
really have some of the best people in
the world
so abide by the islamic principles
that's the catch though because
otherwise corruption is rampant right
corruption is rampant across the world
and i even i often see it as about
people who have power wanting to
maintain their power and i got to be
real with you and we've got some very
corrupt governments
in the middle east but look i think at
the end of the day we're americans
you know i'm an american citizen and
it's my responsibility to hold my
government accountable
and look i'm an attorney
and the older i get man the more
disgusted i become really i mean let's
talk about domestic and then abroad i
mean forget forget abroad i mean forget
abroad let's talk about how we treat our
fellow americans in the united states
through the so-called criminal justice
system that i honestly sometimes those
are the things i'm trying to get i'm
ashamed of and i know that's where
you're going i mean sometimes i'm act i
mean i spoke to a state attorney the top
state prosecutor the other day
and i told him you know i'm not going to
mention his name but he's one of the top
state prosecutors you know uh
overseeing one of the counties here i
said my friend you know
it just looks like our jails are dead or
deals it's jails where the poor get
locked up and the rich get out
and he said haas and i agree so i was
like shame on you then how are you
enforcing these laws in these ways
you know we're so complicit so let's
talk about
the court system the court system
are basically and look people may file
complaints against me with the bar i
don't care we have to speak truth this
is what makes america
have whatever goodness it does have is
our ability to condemn and push for
positive change within our systems but
let's talk about the civil side and the
criminal side so we talk about the civil
side you know when you talk about
marriages and divorces and you talk
about personal interactions again it's
about who can afford the best lawyers
the judges are people who just want
popularity contests they often
especially at the entry court level the
beginner courts they often have very
little knowledge of the law wow they
often i've seen it myself they're more
concerned with the reality tv show they
want to go home to watch then they're
making then the decisions of the cases
that are impacting people's lives
literally people's lives will be at
stake
you know and the court will just
consider the matter life or death
situation for these people about who
gets child custody about a lifetime
worth of assets and how it's divided
judges will barely understand the law
and may make
life or death decisions for these people
in 15 minute hearings that take months
and months to get
and they're often influenced by who has
the best lawyers that can afford the
best lawyers that are the most
well-connected so on the civil side the
process takes way too long
and often it's unqualified judges
unfamiliar with the law
with
paying minimal attention to the facts of
the case who don't even understand the
facts making you know split-second
decisions within 15-minute hearings that
can literally destroy people's lives
so that's what you have on one side then
you talk about the criminal side go
visit a local jail go see who's locked
up it's going to be mostly be brown
black or hispanic people all right
when you visit a jail go in and visit
and talk to people why are they locked
up
many of them they're either locked up
because they couldn't afford to pay some
sort of traffic infraction
okay or they're behind on child support
or they have a drug abuse problem but
meaning they need help you know in each
one of those three cases whether they're
i have some civil infraction that they
can't pay like a traffic ticket speeding
ticket insurance issue or number two uh
you know being behind on child support
payments or number three using drugs
that all indicate a situation of need
often a situation of poverty
many times the people locked up are on
locked up for 200 200 400 500 in bail
people spending months and months in
jail because they can't afford the 500
bail which basically means if you're
poor you get locked up
if you if you're wealthy enough you just
you pay the few hundred dollar bail you
pay a lawyer to go you don't have to
show up for the traffic infraction
they'll take care of it so it's a system
that basically penalizes you for being
poor makes the poor poorer and the rich
richer it's unjust at home and we really
need to reevaluate our laws at home so
that's how we treat each other
domestically imagine how we're treating
those we consider the foreign and the
other you know
talk about the millions of lives that
were killed using u.s taxpayer dollars
talk about the torture we saw in abu
ghraib as you mentioned in guantanamo
which continues to this day
you know uh the more italian i think is
an excellent film i recommend everybody
to see about one of the experiences of
one of the people that was locked up the
mauritanian uh is is is
again highly recommend people to watch
it again normally i don't encourage
people to watch films but something like
this is important for people to be
educated about the experience it's it's
a true story about somebody who's
wrongfully locked up in guantanamo the
documentary dirty wars
i've seen that you know everybody's got
to watch that we literally kill people
like we play video games sitting in the
arizona desert
playing with people's lives with these
so-called signature drone strikes for
example many have argued they create
more terrorists than they kill the night
raids in afghanistan many have argued
they create more terrorism
i don't disagree with that when you drop
a bomb from a drone you're investing
you're you are going to cause more
damage than you're going to cause good
it isn't just top generals either former
cia counterterrorism chief robert
grenier has admitted that drone strikes
are creating more enemies than we are
removing from the battlefield even some
former drone operators themselves have
pointed out that drone strikes have only
fueled the feelings of hatred that
ignited terrorism and groups like isis
while also serving as a fundamental
recruitment tool similar to guantanamo
bay
that kills civilians mostly and you know
what even the person pulling the trigger
doesn't know who the heck he's killing
because what they're killing is
signature so if somebody fits a pattern
if they go to a certain location that's
enough to get them killed
it's disgusting we're killing people
without even knowing how all paid for by
those taxes i don't wonder why they hate
us so again listen we are people of
principle
we're people of peace of justice of
equity we believe that you cannot get
close to the creator without love and
sincere service to the creation and on
the day of judgment after monotheism one
of the first things that people will be
questioned about is sacred blood how you
shed the blood of the creation of god it
doesn't matter what the religion is if
you unjustly shed blood
there will be hell to pay for that
and unfortunately in the u.s we're very
complicit in shedding innocent blood
abroad and
you know we see the havoc of that when
other governments do so
you know we see the uproar against
russia
we should have seen that uproar in the
invasion of iraq and afghanistan and to
be fair we did by some segments of our
fellow americans i mean i remember my
father taking me to dc and we protested
against but it needed to have been
louder
and we see in the end illegal invasion
doesn't work
so this is not about
one religion
versus the other religion or this group
versus that group this is about justice
this is about
you know awakening
you know good human beings who are in
these positions like you mentioned to go
ahead and make a difference to yeah
let's live up to our ideals that's all
i'm calling for look i obviously believe
in america that's i choose to be an
american citizen i choose to live here i
think despite the the horrific problems
our nation has
it's actually still a bit more just than
many others
you know i'm almost afraid to say this
right now because i want to be able to
go perform hajj in umrah but i mean we
all know the saudi government locks up
even imams of the haramain for
condemning evil
and many others who were leading the
prayers at the holiest sites
of the muslim world
arrested when they condemn evil
when they forbid evil when they ordain
good
so our country has its own share of
injustice so i mean our countries our
muslim countries have their own share of
injustice and and we and we condemn it i
mean the syrian government i'm i'm you
know syrian born in syria came when i
was four years old but
the syrian government has killed you
know at least half a million maybe a
million and up of its own civilians to
maintain power
so
unfortunately we have our share of
injustice and i think you know
america has its problems but but we
still have
a lot of freedom to call for positive
change to engage in tawa to share the
beauty of our faith and i think it's our
responsibility as muslim americans to
use that freedom to ordain good forbid
evil and call people to the better path
and i think that you know when you talk
about love you hear these slogans i
think that's out of the muslims love
that he wants
you know for him
for others what he wants for himself so
his muslim neighbor non-muslim neighbor
for his country where he's residing he
wants to make his home land he's i'm a
muslim i'm a muslim american i love my
country but obviously like you said if
you you're not just going to be
you know silent when you see injustices
and like double standards so you see
these things you talk about them you
express yourself so hopefully inshallah
change can possibly happen right
uh africa yes so you you just came from
africa
and you were talking about because a lot
of times we take for granted many of the
love you know people have we have so
many luxuries so many things that we
should be thankful for but you know just
hearing some of the some of your
experiences share that with us so
hopefully that can awaken some of the
people who are also many remind us
myself and others you know to somehow
just be grateful even more so look i
know it's it's almost sort of cliche to
say oh you know africa has its wealth
and its beautiful buildings and its
skyscrapers and that's all true
but we cannot and should not forget the
poverty
that is plaguing many parts of africa
many parts of the middle you see in many
parts even in the u.s but what i saw on
that trip
was really enough to shake you and to
wake you up and to make you cry before
allah of how ungrateful we've been
really and also to open our eyes to the
opportunity
that we have
to make a positive impact not to
belittle any amount of charity
subhanallah i'll tell you on this most
recent trip uh when we landed in mumbasa
we went to to to grab some food
at a local restaurant in mombasa and
when i was leaving the restaurant i had
like a bottle of water just like this
that i hadn't finished so i kept it with
me my intention i was actually thirsty
as well as i was gonna drink it in the
car
and a young child walks up to me
his clothes are torn
shoeless in the heat i thought he was
gonna ask for money subhanallah all he
asked for was the bottle of water if he
could drink the water that i had wow
that's all he wanted
there we have an abundance that we have
abundance of
and that reminds me of subhanallah
you know
on my trip
i've literally seen people walk for
miles and miles to get water and when
they get that water it isn't some clean
water from a fresh well necessarily or
from a lake or a pond or river sometimes
it's just water that's coming out of a
sewer under a road that's muddy that's
brown and they're walking for miles just
to get that water and you still see them
grateful and happy and content despite
the struggle you know we wake up in the
middle of the night man we gotta you
know shower or make will do
alhamdulillah the bathroom's across the
hall or maybe even in our room there's
cold water in our fridge and we still
find reason to be depressed
we still find reason to complain we
still find reason to be ungrateful
whereas literally you go you go to some
of these parts of this world and you
witness people living in mud hunts where
the water that they have is in a bucket
that they walked miles to get
that's brown you think you think this is
something from like 100 years ago this
is happening right now actually actually
the majority of the world struggles with
getting regular consistent clean
drinking water i in fact i gotta look up
the statistics but it's literally
mind-boggling
how are they drinking this water you're
telling me it's like so how are they
drinking subhanallah man i mean they
they have how they're filtering it how
does it work straight straight no
straight sometimes they boil uh but so
hanola i mean their their bodies have
become used to to it it's we couldn't
drink i mean a lot of us we go we get
sick even drinking we can't even drink
the tap water when you go in the city
they got tapa we can't even drink the
tap water they're literally drinking
water that's coming out of pipes that's
that's mixed with the mud that's mixed
with the dirt that's made so hot what
color is that water now it's pretty much
literally it's brown it's brown it's
brown you saw the washi i
i'll show you and i'll send you the
photos that you can include in this you
know subhanallah so i'll send you the
photos it's it's mind-boggling so just
you know allah mentions it really in the
quran and and the prophet i mentioned
hadith we will be asked about the cold
water that we drink
we will be asked about the hot showers
that we can take
we have no right to complain so when you
go and you see how people are living it
really transforms you i remember also
going for a walk on the beach so when i
was going for a walk in the beach i had
my sandals in my hand and a young man
approached me again i thought i was
gonna ask for money
and all he asked for was like brother
those sandals do you need them
if not can i have them
those sandals and the amount actually
without showing their faces i actually
took the pictures of the feet of the
children in the city in the street
how many children walking without shoes
their clothes ripped one of the projects
we did alhamdulillah
when we visited an orphanage and this is
children in the orphanage so imagine
those that aren't there but these are
kids that are being taken care of
most of them had no shoes most of them
had ripped up clothes
and i remember the hadith prophesy said
none of you is a believer unless you
love for your brother what you love for
yourself
you know we accept that for ourselves we
accept that for our own kids
and allah reward the orphan caretakers
but they themselves are poor and we'll
talk about the caretakers in a minute
but when i
saw the situation i suggested to the
brothers see what we do is we take
mashallah wealthy businessmen leaders
and we take them with us to see what's
happening then they can fund the
projects
by themselves and a healthy team you say
we have a zero percent overhead policy
so whatever donations we get we
distribute we don't keep anything for
our overhead it's covered from private
private funders
subhanallah we we saw those kids and i
didn't just want to buy them clothes and
give them clothes i said these kids have
never had the opportunity to pick up
their own clothes so at the we made an
arrangement with the local shop we took
all the kids from the orphanage to go
into the store pick up their own outfit
clothes shoes you know shirts everything
and like it was the first time in their
life they got to do that and you see
just their smiles and the happiness
on their face you know these are small
things that we can do but they really go
a long way to just
building hope building inspiration but
it's about being sustainable so and
handle we go to africa now once or twice
a year we maintain relationships with
those orphanages we've also built from
the ground up alhamdulillah a boys
orphan village that can accommodate 160
orphans with the best level of care
meanwhile we're still trying to provide
support for a lot of the run-down
orphanages because you can't ignore them
i mean the kids are going to be there
regardless so we try to do what we can
but so i remember visiting one of these
orphanages man and i asked the
orphan caretaker like how can we support
you what do you need and we sometimes do
like sustainability projects for them
like we'll open up a business for them
we'll get them a water tank where they
can sell and distribute water in their
local village and they can earn money
that supports the upkeeping of the
orphanage but that one man do you know
somehow what they asked us for aki they
said we couldn't pay our orphan
caretakers this month they had five
orphan caretakers they all teach the
foreign heads they take care of them
said okay what's their salary
their salary was just 50 a month
that's like 15
less than fifteen dollars a week twelve
dollars a week
we had one of the brothers with us we
took out you know five fifty dollar
bills 250 dollars we paid the entire
orphan caretaker salaries for the month
you know a little bit money goes a long
way in in one of the best orphanages we
have i'll finish with this point the
best orphanages we have you know how
little it costs to feed the entire
orphanage we ask them because there's
people who want to sponsor meals
and it just costs a hundred dollars
not just for one meal but for an entire
days of meals for three meals a day for
a hundred orphan girls which is one
hundred dollars we'll buy breakfast
lunch and dinner and good quality food
for a hundred orphan girls how many of
us can't afford to do that you know even
if we're struggling maybe we can once a
year if not once a month sacrifice fifty
dollars a hundred dollars and give a
full meal to a hundred orphans and
imagine the reward of that on day of
judgment in the last minute um how do
you connect now to
if you
look at the situation here where you
have somebody who's still hopefully
they're watching this and they see their
fridge and now it's full but then they
complain we don't have enough and half
the food sometimes goes to waste right
or you see hey i gotta have this sneaker
and not satisfied with a good quality
shoe that might be 30 40 bucks and you
mentioned this kid just wants a sandal
no but i got to have the jordans i got
to have whatever the latest in there
like a hundred a buck uh 20 120. or they
got to have you know the the
there
there's no talk about target or walmart
no they have to go to the you know to
the uh
store with the finer brands right so
you know i think they got to come out
with us and see how tough life is for a
lot of people to understand how blessed
they are you know one of the things i've
learned the lessons i learned last year
is listen especially for us in the west
whether our fridges are full or empty
our stomachs are always full allah
always takes care of us we have always
beyond our need it's not about how much
you have it's really about